leading the charge amongst those
conservative mps is the former
international
development secretary andrew mitchell
and he
joins us now andrew mitchell
um what did you think of what
dominic robb said earlier on about
why he thought that the billion vaccines
on the schedule that they're
proposing is pretty much the best you're
going to get
well i think the summit has been
extremely successful
in focusing on the key issues and i
think
the prime minister deserves great credit
for having got the
other six leaders of the richest
countries in the world
to focus on the things that really
matter particularly in the middle of a
global pandemic so i think as far as it
goes
those issues are the ones which we now
need to
uh really push forward and the the um
really the question is this
uh is there enough money these are the
richest countries in the world
is there enough money to drive forward
the vaccination of the world which is
the
prime minister's ambition and upon which
our national interests and our welfare
depend on the future
um and i think the jury so far is out on
that we'll see whether or not the summit
communique
uh commits the richest countries to step
up to the plate
and of course i have to say it's been
more difficult for the prime minister to
do that
when in the previous two uh global
summits uh in
in birmingham and in glen eagles in
britain
britain really led from the front on on
development on tackling poverty
on bringing the world together on that
agenda it's been more difficult to do
that this time
because britain is the only g7 country
that is reversing that
is cutting its aid when all the others
are either increasing it or at least
keeping it at the same level and the
impact of that is very severe and it
will impact not only
our ability to achieve these objectives
but also to tackle the
global pandemic one example i would give
you is this that
we are we are slashing spending on clean
water and sanitation
which is actually absolutely critical to
combating
the pandemic and as a result of this 80
percent
cut by britain on water and sanitation
10 million of the poorest people
will not this year get access to it
i i put that point actually to dominic
rob earlier on and he said well
you know we have to balance the needs of
the economy
and of course security where we're
spending more money on uh
soldiers he used we use the example of
mali
and we're doing as much as we can do um
do you buy that
well you know the in the scheme of
things this cut
is one percent of what we spent tackling
kovid quite rightly last year it's one
percent and it's the only cut that was
announced in the otherwise
excellent comprehensive spending review
last november and it's not a cut we have
to make and
in in comparison with anything else as i
said it's a very small amount
of money but the impact it's going to
have not just
you know on on the poorest people in the
world which will be
huge but also on britain's reputation
and britain's ability
to move the dial on these very important
international issues will be
be great and i i heard what the foreign
secretary said about
mali but i thought that the point you
made was a very good one if you put
200 300 troops in harm's way in
in mali but you also scrap much of the
international development program
across that area of sahel which means
you take away the hope
and the optimism of of women to be able
to get
access to birth control of children to
go to school of of
of communities that are teetering on the
edge of starvation you take that away
it actually acts as a sort of recruiting
sergeant for the
terrorist message and and that's not a
good position when you're putting
british troops into that sort of
uh theater it sounds like you are
putting the government
on a warning and that you are going to
be back
with an attempt to restore that 0.7
percent
uh development budget 0.7 of the
of gross domestic product development
budget that the government
has reduced to 0.5 percent is that right
you're going to be back
for another go
yes we are and the government should
should accept the olive branch
we suggested in parliament which is to
bring back the 0.7 from january
next year when the economy will have
rebounded we've seen the
excellent economic news thanks to the
chancellor's good stewardship of our
economy uh in even in today's uh papers
um but we've got to be really really
careful about this and the government
should listen to its friends we are
supporters of the government we are
campaigners for the conservative party
we are people who've got the
government's best interests at heart and
we urge the government to listen to what
the house of commons is saying
the government does not command the
house of commons on this issue last week
they would have lost a vote had it uh
gone ahead now
the government should listen to what its
friends are saying accept the olive
branch
and bring back the 0.7 as we all
promised at the last general election
as soon as possible and preferably in
january next year
some of the government's other friends
are not saying what you're saying
what they're saying is we can't afford
to spend the money that we need to get
our children to catch up for the
education
that they've lost in the last 18 months
and
in the red wall what they're saying red
wall seats
what the the tories have just recently
acquired
that what they're saying is why are we
spending money
on other nations children when we can't
even
educate our own
i i am very clear that we need to do
both those two things and
you know we've been joined by uh quite a
large number of brilliant colleagues
from these red wall seats the
boris has spread the dna of the tory
party
very well into the red wall seats we've
won seats we've never had before and
i campaigned in some of them in the west
midlands and when i asked people whether
they were
voting conservative they said no i'm
voting for boris so
you know he has widened the tory party's
dna
very well but we mustn't forget the
lessons we learned in 2015 it took the
tory party 23 years to win an overall
majority in parliament 1992-2015
and the reason we won in 2015 was
because the tory party's dna
embraced internationalism it embraced uh
the very important
message to many people on international
development and on the importance of
tackling
these quite extraordinary discrepancies
of wealth and opportunity
which disfigure our world in which our
generations
are able to do so much about um and that
that meant that all those liberal seats
and people who were sort of on the
margins of the tory party
they came and they supported the tory
message because it was a broad church
and what we've got to be very careful
about is we don't add this
extra very important dna at one end and
lose it at the other end because we turn
our backs on two decades where
britain under both parties it hasn't
been a sort of labor or conservative
policy
it's been a policy of britain to to
really
lead the world on tackling international
development that's not only about money
it's also about the
policy generation from our great
universities and
think tanks but britain has had that
leadership centrally and it's been very
noticeable you know you only have to
look at the briefings
during this g7 summit that that
leadership and that thrust
has not been there because we've broken
our promise on the point seven
but andrew mitchell um you you you're a
former
chief whip you can count the numbers as
well as anybody else
and actually boris johnson has a bigger
majority than any conservative leader
for
some time and actually he is where head
in the polls
is your real worry here a longer term
one that the cut to international
development money will make the tories
look
like what people used to say they are
the nasty party
uh i think that the tory party is full
of volunteers who
are part of the great ngo alliance crack
the crisis which
you know has got more than 10 million
supporters and often you know
conservative
uh branch uh officers are also the
people who help
run oxfam and save the children and
other great charities throughout our
country we are
we are a big-hearted broad party that
really care about these issues and and i
worry that in the
in the rather mean and almost dickensian
approach to our development
spend where we've cut it in the middle
of a pandemic in breach of the promises
we all made
all 650 of us at the last general
election
arguably in breach of the law very
senior lawyers in britain have said that
this
this is unlawful because it's not
missing the target it's changing the
target 2.5
and also the promises we made to the
united nations and on the floor of the
general assembly
i i think it's very bad for britain's
image but above all
it's bad for the party and it's bad for
our reputation
and our ability to move the dial in some
very wretched and poor parts of the
world
very last quick question about june 21st
because it's a big signal
whether the government decides it wants
to coexist
and will open up or whether it is going
to be cautious
and stick keep to tr try to
suppress the virus even further where
are you standing on this are you looking
forward to
weddings with more than 30 people and
being out
in a barbecue where you don't have to
wear a mask
well my own my own lovely daughter has
had to delay her
wedding now for the second year so she's
had she's going to have to wait two
years now before she's able to
marry her partner so i feel very very
very strongly for people whose
weddings have been postponed uh in that
way and i feel desperately sorry for the
hospitality industry throughout the
royal town of sutton coalfield which has
suffered so grievously but i think we
must follow the science and i have
great faith that the prime minister will
reach the right conclusions so i'm
looking forward
to hearing what he what his judgment is
tomorrow